これからお釈迦様の瞑想法を紹介する時間でございます
まああの 大変いろいろ瞑想っていうのは世の中にいっぱいありまして
皆様結構悔しいと思うんですけど
まあお釈迦様はまあそういうことを言うと
ものすごい簡単に誰にでもできる
簡単に心清らかにする瞑想っていうものを教えております
それを紹介したいと思います
あんまり簡単だから まあそれほどまあ元気やるというわけではないんですけど
まあ大体人々というのは瞑想みたいなことを通して
すごい神秘的な世界を探検しようとか
まあそういうすごい大胆な目的を持ってますからね
まあそういう場合はなかなかこの瞑想っていうのは決して物足らないと思うのが
我々の日常生活の中で
穏やかな心で清らかな心で苦しみなく悩みなく生きていられる方法だと思います
また 心の中で怒りやら憎しみやら
まああらゆる混乱や まあそういうものがあると
まあ大変苦しいということになるんです
まあそちらにも異論がありまして
欲がないと楽しくないんではないかとかね
怒りがないと頑張れるんではないかとかね
まあそういう方々はそれで結構でしょうし
いっぱい欲張って怒りに勝って元気で明るく生活すればよろしいんですけど
またいじくの人々はまあこれが大変迷惑やと思う方々もいる
ですから このまあこの瞑想で
そんなにも欲張ることもなく
怒ることもなく 穏やかに生活できると思います
そういうことで このすごい単純な瞑想法でございますので
まあ方法を教えますから頑張ってみてください
普段は私は皆様にいろいろ質問があるならば
まあお返事いたしますので
質問を出してくださいとは言うことはありますが
今まで一度も質問を出されたことはありません
それわけで そういう疑問とか質問とか持っていると思えないし
質問まあ一応まあ今日はこの
キリスト教の文化のやる時は正月の初めでもありますから
皆様大変元気でお正月を伝統的にお祝いするもんだから
それにちなんで仏教経典を紹介したいと思います
まあ知っていますけど
我々仏教徒にはこういう
グレゴリオさんのカレンダーによる正月はお祝いしません
これはまあそんな あまり原始人だからね
私たちは だから日本とすごい伝統を持っているわけじゃないし
だから正月は別の日なんです
ローマの文化でなく グレゴリというキリスト教の頭を抱えてる聖人というんですけどね
その人が決めた日なんです
1月1日は また遠い昔から人間っていうのは
もう ギリシアのなんとか神かな
生まれた日やとか 日をお祝いしていて
それは何か知らないうちにジーザスという人の誕生日になってしまって
まあそういうことで まあそれはその文化は私たちにございませんので
それはちょっとお祝いすることはできません
まあとにかく皆様にとってみれば大変尊い
めでたいお正月ですから
それに関連で仏教のお話を一つ紹介します
お釈迦様がこの 苦しみに
あの すごく気になっていたんです
人間には限りない苦しみがあると
まあ昔のことですからね
今の方々だったらそうは思わないんですけどね
まあ大変幸福に溢れて生きてるんではないかっていうのは現代の方々の考え方で
昔は皆様みたいにそんなに恵まれていた社会ではございませんので
やっぱり人々には生きる苦しみっていうのはありましたし
で この生きるっていうことは
このすごく苦しいことであって
まあどこな側面を見ても大変やと
例えばね お釈迦様が生まれた地方っていうのは
このまあほとんど農民でしたし
平和的で まあ田んぼを作ってね
米をよく作っていたみたいです
で 作って まあ生活していたんです
そんなにまあ 誰に迷惑かけることはなく
戦うこともなく しかし
自分で田んぼを作って生活していても
それでうまくいくわけじゃないんですね
あっちこっちからまあ力強い人々が来て攻撃したりする
ものを奪ったりする 侵略されたりもする
それで守るのは大変なんですね
自分 ただ突然誰かがもう軍隊が出て
まあ全部村人を殺して帰っちゃうとかね
で 朝目が覚めたら自分が家がもう土地が別な国のものになったとかね
ということっていうのはよくありましたし
で お釈迦様はまあ何でしたっけね
まあ一応この管理をする
まあカースト過程で生まれていたんだから
国民を支配管理しなくちゃいけないんですね
で そうするとこの国民の財産とか土地とかね
隣の国に侵略されちゃうと
うちらが行ってそれを守ってあげなくちゃいけない
で これ戦うことにもなっちゃうし
で 戦争して戦っても国を守ることはできないし
とにかく力強い人がまあ占領しちゃうんですね
戦略的で まあそういう苦しみっていうのはよくありましたし
だから全くこの平和な時代生きてきてる現代の方々にはちょっと理解できない人が
やっぱり死んでしまうっていうことはね
おいしくも死んでしまうんだと
だから親しい人が突然殺されたり死んだりすると
これは大変悲しいことでね
で お釈迦様にすごい期待していたんですね
まあかなり能力はありましたし
当時はものすごい信じられないほどの天才みたいな
天才っていうかね すごい能力はありましたし
で なんて言いますか 大体もう 20年
30年ぐらいかかるんですよ
まあ勉強するためには
なのにこれがもうほとんど 2
3年で終わってしまったんです
だからみんなすごいびっくりするんです
いた当時の先生たちは
この子供にはもう対応できないという
で それでまあこんなに能力あるし
まあそれでまあ軍隊をというかね
軍事的な軍人としての訓練も全て早く早く終わってしまって
それでまあ完璧な 戦車としてね
まあまあ昔は王というんですかね
まあ王としての仕事はできる
うーん まあ他の国々の王たちと比べてみると
まあこれすごい能力ありましたから
なんとか国民を守ってくれるだろうと
これでその釈迦という釈迦族ですね
その釈迦族の国がなんとか繁栄して
すごい国になるんではないかなという期待があった
でお釈迦さんはやっぱり真剣に自分の仕事を考えたんです
で 自分の仕事は国民の苦しみと期待
難問になって 期待に応えることなんですね
しかし 勉強しすぎたかどうかわかりませんだけど
この期待には応えられないんだと
自分が何をやっても 人間には苦しみっていうものあるんだと
王として何かできることっていうのは何もないんだと
そういうこと 人々はもう我々の救い主であるという風にすごい
期待しているんだからね
これはやりきれなかったんですね
国民はすごい期待して
父親もまた父親もすごい期待していたんです
自分の家に希望の星が生まれてきたんだと
で 占ってみたら もうこの人はもう人類の唯一の人物であると
こんな人っていうのはもう二度と生まれませんと
という で 占ったりして
まあ宗教的な話だから
あまりもう現代の方々は認めないかもしれませんけど
とにかくエピソード見るとから見るとね
まあ人類の を幸福に導く人で生まれているんではないか
あなたはというと まあこれかなりストレス
プレッシャーがかかるんです
で 父親と国民は王様として国を整理してほしいし
で 父親がもうそういうわけだから
自分が一応やらなくてもいいんじゃないかと
国民が早くも幸せになってくれればいいんじゃないかということで
まあ随分若い時に王として仕事しなさいと
王様 父親がやっぱり勉強したいんで
自分はすごい若いんですけど
父親 まあどちらかというと大体 18歳で結婚しましたけどね
まあ王様はもう勉強終わって全部終わって
もう立派な 1人前になって結婚させましたし
では 政治家にしてどうでしょうかということなんですけど
あまりお釈迦様は王様の仕事を全部じゃあ私がやってやりますよということはなかったみたいし
どちらかというと遊んでいたんです
うん でお父様の方もまあいいんじゃないかな
自分の息子でしょうし
もう随分信頼しているし
まあ自分も若くて まあ仕事はできるし
まあそれ若い時はね 楽しくいればいいんじゃないかなということで
放っておいてあったんです
で すごい贅沢 宮殿は 3つありまして
1年間でその 4ヶ月  4ヶ月回ったりして
24時間お世話係の人々は回るんです
で だから人々は自分が寝ていても人々は寝ない
お世話する人々 ずっと回り
もう待ってるんです すぐそのうちに目が覚めたら何か言ったら
すぐそれに対応しなくちゃということで
まあそれぐらい人々はあまりにも期待しているんだなと
自分がちょっとちょこちょこ遊んでるだけで
それで真剣に考えたんですね
この人々は何を期待するのかと
私にはこの期待に応えられるのかと
よく人々のことを見ると
まあ人間というのは限りない苦しみを味わっているんだと
苦しみって何なのかと
ということで 苦しみについて研究してみたんです
だからそこら辺で世間にある哲学者やらね
宗教家とちょっと違うんですね
世界はこの神は何でしょうかというすごいことを調べるのに
あれほど頭が良かったお釈迦様
そんなのあまり気にしなかったんですね
だから仏教というのはすごい単純心配でわかりやすい宗教になっているんです
すごい堂々たる宗教ではないんです
もうただ単純に神はなんじゃということではなくて
もう我々の苦しみってなんじゃと単純なことを考えるんですね
そうすると まあ人間にはものすごい苦しみがあるということなんです
すごい心配なんですよ
人が突然死ぬと これってすごい悲しい苦しいことである
決して人間 そんな馬鹿げたことを考えませんよ
あまりにも単純で まずそういうことを考える
そんな当たり前のことを何やと
親しい人が死ぬと悲しいと
病気になってしまうと
これってすごい嫌なことだと
それまで年取ってしまうっていうのはね
これってすっごい嫌やと
そういうもう皆様から見れば笑われるほど単純なことをお考えになるんですよ
仏教徒は決してそういうことは問題にしないでしょうし
まあどちらかというとそんなことはあるはずもないというね
先帝で神は何ぞやとかね
魂はなんだやろうとかね
もう霊魂は確かにあるとか
そういうことを調べているのに
俺がもう本当にまあ小学生みたいな感じで
もう嫌やと 小学生の子供も同じでしょうに
もう自分飼ってたペットがもうモルモットでも何でもね
まあ死んじゃうってよく泣いちゃうんだからね
まあ大人は立派だといいんだから
そんなことで泣けませんし
ね 子供はもうネズミとか飼ったりすると
それ早く死んじゃいますよ
そこで自分のポケットに入れて
もう色々遊んだりして
チューしたり いろんなことをして遊んでる
あの あの なんとかっていうネズミ
あれなんてネズミでしたっけ？ ハムスター
ハムスターとかね あれ飼ってて
あれ死んじゃっちゃうと
結構ショック受けちゃって泣いたりする
まあお釈迦様はだいたいあんな程度なんで
これ悲しいと 親しいものから別れるっていうことはね
そういうことで 一番人間にとっては苦しい大変な悩みっていうのは
この死や年取ることや病気になることやね
また あれこれとかね まあ期待したり努力したりするんですけど
期待はその通りに行くっていうことはないんです
特に昔はね まあただもう種をまいてもしっかりとあの出来上がるっていうことはね
わかりません まあ動物が来て食べちゃうかもしれませんし
雨が降らない 降らなかったかもしれませんし
もうあるいは洪水で全部流されてしまう可能性もあるし
だから現代とは随分違うんです
今はカンタスもね まあ農業したらカンタスも実るというね
期待通りになるということはありますけどね
まあ昔はそうなかったんです
雨が降ったり降らなかったりもする
洪水に流れたりもする
自然災害はありましたしね
だからこの期待がなくなるっていうことはすごい悲しいことですよ
米がせっかく作ったら取れなかったらね
その人々にとっては これは大変な経済的なダメージなんです
一年間もう食べるものがなくなっちゃうんです
あるいは なんとか なんとか
他のいろんな食べるものを探して
探して 大変苦しい生活しなくちゃいけない
例えば 米全部稲がなくなっちゃうと
じゃあ今年なくなっても
じゃあ次来年作りましょうと
もしかすると種までなくなっちゃいますからね
次の年はきちんと雨が降ってくれても
うまく実がなくなっちゃいますからね
だから大変でしたからね
まあそういうのは苦しいと
期待が外れること それから嫌な人々と付き合うこと
それも現代人にはなかなか経験できないことで
まあ結構若い時と付き合いたくないんですけど
付き合わなくちゃいけないという
大変なもう苦しい状況に置かれちゃう時はあります
例えば 自分の地方は誰かにもう暴力団みたいな乱暴な人々に占領される
今まで自分の土地でしたけど
これは 1日にして別な人のものになる
自分たちがそれで奴隷みたいに仕事をしなくちゃいけない
田んぼを作りたい で 無賃労働
自分の田んぼなんですけど
昨日まで で それでまた作ってそちらにあげなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
だからその命令を聞かなくちゃいけないし
占領されちゃうと まあこの占領者の機嫌を取らなくちゃいけない
これすごい我慢できないんです
自分の土地 自分の国が別な人々に取られやがって
それまたその人々の命令に従って
奴隷みたいな生活までしなくちゃいけない
これはものすごい想像を絶する苦しみなんです
だから 嫌な人と付き合うこと
好きな人々から離れること
限りない苦しみですよ
だからブッダのこの第一番目に気になったことは
この現代の世界では全く気にしないことにはなってます
そんなのはあるわけじゃないというね
で お釈迦様はそんなのは普遍的なことであると
その苦しみは 本当に普遍性がないかっていうことは
皆さんは考えなくちゃいけないんです
我々に得ている苦しみは何かあるのかどうかね
で お釈迦様は人間の苦しみというのは普遍的なことであると
まあ普遍的っていう言葉は
まあこのいつでも同じっていう意味なんですね
で こんな人間頑張っても普遍的なことは変えられません
うん 例えばね まあ地球は自転するとかね
まあ夏は暑くなるとかね
夏は日が長いとかね そういうのは普遍的なことなんです
そう簡単に変えることはできません
まあ将来変えるかどうかはわかりませんだけど
だから人間のこの苦しみ
親しい人々と別れること
人たちが死んでしまうことは悲しいとか
そういうのは普遍的なことですと
期待が外れること 年取ることは苦しいんだと
病気になることも大変嫌な苦しいことでした
それでどこに満足できる生き方もしてないのに
もうこれからもこれからもこれからと思ってずっと生きてるのに
これから幸せになるんではないかと
これからも成功してやろうではないかと頑張っているのに年取っているんですよ
振り返ってみると これは 60歳
70歳になっても まあこれからやと思っているんです
それで結局はまあこれから幸せになろうではないかなと思っていると死んでしまうんです
これすごい苦しいんですよ
まあ十分生きてましたとね
もうやりたいことは何一つ
心残りなくできましたと
何でも成功しましたと
もう生きる生きる意味目的に達しましたとと思うならば
死ぬことというのは別に大変苦しいことじゃないんです
これからなんとかうまくいくんじゃないかなと思っている間に死ぬんです
そういうことがお釈迦様を考えたんですよ
そんなに難しいことを考えたわけじゃないんです
大体子供ならわかるんですよ
これがなかなか大人には理解できないんです
あまりにも心配しすぎちゃって
だって大人理解できないでしょ？あのハムスターが亡くなって死んじゃったんだから
子供はすごい泣いてると
大人から見たらやっぱり子供やとかね
子供もわからないんだからと
すごくバカにしてみるでしょ
まあバカにすると言ったって
自分の子供だからね 隣の子供だったらバカにするんですけど
まあ自分の子供だったらもうすごいもう心配して可愛がったりする
だからこのお釈迦様の言った真理っていうのは
まあそれは子供ならわかると思います
子供というのは平気で言うんですね
死ぬのは嫌やとかね 怖いとかね
大人は言わないんですね
だから時々子供が死ぬのは嫌やと大人のお母さんに言っちゃうと
自分はなんか変なことばっかしやがってとかね
何考えてるんだ くだらないことと
すごい知識で子供の気持ちを潰してあげるんですよ
お釈迦様が言ったのはそれぐらいの真理なんですよ
だから魂はなんぞや？とかね
神様の存在はなんとかして証明してくれとかね
そんなことを頼んだってないんです
ま そういう単純なことで考えたら
次のお釈迦様の出た問題は
では私にはそれに答えることはできますか？と
みんなの期待に みんな苦しみから解放してくれと頼んでいるでしょうに
では あんた方の苦しみを私に何ができるかと
何もできないでしょ 大体やっぱりまあもう 10歳
8歳  9歳ぐらいの子供のレベルで考えないと
それこそわからなくなっちゃうんです
人が自分の親が死んで
まあ今は泣かないんですけど
昔はね 親が死ぬと悲しくなるんですよ
あるいはまあそれほどまあ治療とかね
もうそんなあったわけじゃないんだからね
ちょっとした病気で子供が死んじゃうでしょうしね
子供が死んでしまうと親が悲しくなっちゃうんです
昔はね 今は子供作りませんから
悲しくなることじゃないでしょうしね
だからまあ昔はそれ悲しいと思っちゃうんです
それでこのそういうレベルで考えると
この対応できない もう応じられませんということが出てくるんですよ
だからどうすれば子供は死ねないようにしてあげることできるのかと
例えば子供にしたって
どうすれば自分の両親が死ねないようにしてあげることできますかと
どうすれば年取れないようにしてあげることできるのかと
これできないでしょ 期待は何でも叶えるようにと
失望にならないようにしてあげると
これはできないと だから人はいくら期待したっても
これは勘違いだと 自分に期待していること自体が
人類を救ってくれるんではないかと
だから人が救ってくれると何を思ったかわかりませんだけど
お釈迦様の単純な考え方を見れば
救うとかなんとかではなくて
人間が苦しんでいると
だから何か夢見ているんだと
幸福なものというね 幸福になりたいという
なんであんた方夢見てるのかというと
結局あんた方苦しんでるんだと
苦しみって何なのかと言ったところで
これはもうどうにもならん
これは普遍的な法則ですと
これはどうにもならん
それで自分の天才的な能力をそれから機能しだしちゃったんです
じゃあ何とか方法ないのかと
ということで とにかく自分にはもう期待に応じることはできない
だからもうおる意味がない
出て行けと すべて辞めて出て行けと
ということで もう全て捨てて
出てることに決めたんですね
社会にいるということは
社会に責任があるんです
しかし その責任は果たせない
明確に果たせない 責任も果たせないくせに責任を持ってはいけないでしょうに
これまた単純な考え方なんですよ
もう現代人とは違うんです
現代人はいくら責任絶対果たせませんだけど
とことん握りたいほど握っちゃいますよ
頭が悪ければ悪いほど
才能がなければないほど
すごいそういうものを必要とする立場を取っちゃうんです
例えば国民として権利まででも
国民権利でももう取り消した方がいい人が国の総理になったり
大臣になったりする どれほど能力ないかというと
この国民でいることさえも迷惑というぐらいなんです
大体そんなもんなんですよ
インチキ泥棒やってる人々はもうずっと会社で昇格していくんです
嘘を言って人を騙してごまかし
それが普通の常識な社会なんです
正直でコツコツ仕事すると簡単にクビになるんです
何かごまかしをやらないと
[no sound]だからこのしかし
子供のぐらいになってくると正直ですよ
できないことを頼んじゃうとすっごく嫌になるんです
できることを頼んでやるとすっごい喜んでやってくれるんです
それで褒めてほしくなっちゃうんです
だからお釈迦様はやっぱりまあそんな程度で
もう私はこんな責任持てないんだと
できないことを頼んでいるんだと
子供にもできないことを頼んじゃうと何するんですかね
絶対やらないですよ やってみようってこともしない
嫌やと 平気で言うんです
だからお釈迦様はやっぱりもう社会人でいてはいけないんだと
社会人とは社会が期待する責任を果たさなくちゃいけない
自分に抱えている期待っていうのもあんまりにも大きすぎ
幸せにしてあげなくちゃいけないんだから
幸せにするっていうことは
みんながやることではなくて
これはもうみんな苦しんでいるんだから幸せになりたがっているんだよと
だから苦しみって何なの？苦しみを消さなくちゃいけないし
これは消せないんですね
ということは幸せになれないんです
だから期待したっても
期待には応える 叶ってあげることはできない
だったら社会人でいてはいけないと
なことで出家して しかし
そこから自分の天才的な能力を働かせちゃって
ただ別な道を探さなくちゃいけないんだと
何かあるんではないかと
この苦しみをなくすという
それで もういろいろ研究やら修行やらしてみて
お釈迦様はその方法見つかるんですね
そこをまだ残念なことに
この現代の方々にはちょっと理解できないんですね
この苦しみっていうのはちょっとした精神的な問題ですというね
それはもう何の事の心の問題ですと
雨が降らなかったんだから不幸になったんじゃなくて
これはちょっとした心の問題ですと
子供が死んだら不幸になったという話
これは心の問題ですと
この普遍的な法則があって
それが理解しないという無知だと
生まれるものは誰でも知るのに
なんでそれ認めないんですかと
認めないのは心の問題ではないかと
死んでほしくない 死んでほしくないと思う
生まれたものは誰でも年取るのに
ああそうかっていうぐらいで終わればいいのに
それを認めないところに問題があるんだと
ということで これはまあ心の問題にしちゃったんです
それで心を育てること
心を綺麗にすること 知恵を開発することということを探し出して
その道を歩んで知恵を開発したんです
全ての物事はどのように現れて
どのように消えていくのか
お釈迦様は明確にそれを知り尽くしちゃったんです
それでお釈迦様は断言するんですね
生命には知るべきものはそれしかないんだと
それで生命に知り得るものっていうのは一切それに限ると
だから自分が全て知ったんだと
ということは まあ堂々と言うんです
知らないものは何もないと
それからもうチャレンジしたんです
もし知らないものがあったら言って皆さんと言って
人類に 仏法っていうのはそうやって人々はお釈迦様にチャレンジしていくんです
いろんな質問で いろんな疑問で
それには答えていくんです
その答えたものが仏法になっています
だから自分たちも心でチャレンジして
持っていないと質問出さないと仏教はわからないんです
仏教を理解したくなければ
一番いい方法っていうのは黙っていることなんです
そうすると全く理解できない状態で
すごく頭がいい状態で残ります
で 黙っていないで これは何や
これは何でこうなるんでしょうかとかね
という風に自分について質問出してみると
残念なことに仏教を理解する羽目になっちゃうんです
それなんとなくわかってくると
その時点でみんな質問するのをやめるんです
時々人々は質問するんですよ
質問に私なんか答えちゃうと
なんか一部仏教を理解したことになるんです
それでその時点で質問全部やめたんです
それでもう守られます
そのまんまで何も知らない状態でいることはできます
で 質問しようと思ったって出てこないんです
じゃあ騙して質問してやれそうだができない
渾身のことだから 知りたくないってことはあるんだからね
まあ一応ブッダの教えっていうのは
そうやって人の質問に答えるということでずっと成り立っていたんです
お釈迦様に答え返事できなかった質問っていうのは
一つも誰にも出すことはできなかった
できませんでしたし だけど皆様から見れば
当時の連中は何も知らないバカでしたから
ろくな質問出さなかったでしょうという推測できるんです
ですから 私は では皆様は現代知識で質問を出してみてくださいと
ブッダは負けるかないかと
いうチャレンジはしているんです
ブッダの代わりに お釈迦様もう年六百年だからね
前だから まあそこまいでちょっと時代変わったでしょ
知識も変わったでしょう
学問もなんだかんだ ですから
当時の人に出せなかった答え
質問と答えて 今現代人には出せます
僕はいつでもオープンチャレンジでいるんです
質問があったら出してみと
それでお釈迦様がこの修行して真理を発見して
この心の問題であるということも発見して
で 自分が自分の心のその問題を解決したんです
世の中とか生命っていうのはね
宇宙というかなんだかんでも
どんなカラクリで出来上がるものかと
命はどんなカラクリで出来上がるものかと
物事はどういうカラクリで出来上がるものかと
その秘密をわかったんです
それで世の中はその秘密にもう神というんですね
神といったってのは これは数学でなんとかわからないものに
とかとかね 何か総じてるようなことで X
は全てですとは言えますよ
しかしXって何と で この数学的な問題解く場合は
そうやってこのわからない知りたいものにもうXかAかもうYか何とか
あの数字入れるんです
おそらく日本でもローマ字使うでしょ
で ローマ字とギリシャ文字とかね
アルファとかね ガンマとかね
ジンマとかそういう何か使う
だから例えばテータとかね
テータの中身が何かとわからないんですよ
それで知ってるデータいっぱい入れて
他のも計算して計算して
最後にテータイコールこれこれやら出てくるんです
まあそれでこの存在 生命
すべてということに これがもう神というXというね
ことにしてしまって これですごい分かったような気がしますよ
数字入れただけで これから大変なんです X
は何やと計算していかないとけないんだから
それが哲学でもあるし
宗教でもあるし お釈迦様は最初からそんなこと考えてなかったんです
まずデータから言っちゃったんです
存在の秘密は何やではなくて
存在は何やと 言うと ただの苦しみでしょう
普遍的にあるんだと 変わらないんだと
これが 生まれたらそれまた苦しいし
生まれた時点でもう大変な問題なんです
もう生きていられない
それで生まれた瞬間のその時点で
もうすごい苦しみ そこをなんとかなると解決したかというと解決してないんですよ
生まれた瞬間っていうのは
赤ちゃんにとってはものすごいもう死ぬことと同じぐらい苦しみなんです
これがもう想像できないぐらい苦しみですよ
みんな経験しているんですけど
でもなんとかそこはもうなんとか
なる それで問題解決したかというと
そうじゃない それからまたまた苦しい
また苦しい これで死ぬまで続くんです
生まれた瞬間でもこれからやってしょ
これから良くなるんだよと
これが死ぬ瞬間まで長い
だからこれが普遍的な苦しみであると
それを発見して だからこの苦しみは精神的なことであると
それをまた発見して では自分で解決してみようかと
それを解決してみると
この過程で全ての生命のカラクリを見えてきたんです
それすごい具体的というか
はっきりしたことなんですね
神を発見したじゃないんです
すべての一切の存在のカラクリを発見したんです
存在のカラクリはもう西洋的な思考で言えば神なんです
そのカラクリに  これ単なる方程式ですからね
一応 この存在の方程式を発見した
発見したという方程式
それわかったら全部わかるんです
アインシュタインのなんとか方程式あるでしょ
相対論なんとかの そんな感じで
アインシュタインもあらゆるデータを調べたところで
なるほど こんなもんやと
こういう方程式と発見するんです
アインシュタインの相対論も全部存在を説明するものでしょ
物質の存在 心の存在ではなくて
まあでも彼がこれが違いますよと
それからそうと踏ん張っちゃったんです
しかし 他の科学者はもういい
それが正しいと発見した
このみんな逆らってもう言っていたんだから
おそらくアインシュタインもそれで全部説明してないんじゃないかなという概念があったでしょうと思います
本当に説明してないんです
それでは全部 もう一つ方程式ありましたしね
心の方程式っていうのも
それは全く流行らなかったんだから
物質っていうのは心と物質がお互いに機能するんだから
なんかどこかでちょっと物足らないんですね
しっかりしないんです
その方程式が だからまあアインシュタインはそこでまた神という概念導入し始めて
もうなんとか頑張ってみようではないかと
完全じゃないことくらいあの人は分かっていたんですけども
でも科学者はそこではまあ純粋物理唯物論者たちだから
これでぴったしやということになってしまったんです
実験すればするほど正しいと出てくるのではないかと
だからこのデータ調べてから方程式を発見する
それですごいちま ちまるんです
お釈迦様がそれで全ての存在という一切のこのカラクリってどうやって
現れて消えていくのかと
それ知ったらもう全て知ってることなんです
その方程式に当てはめないもの何一つないんです
で この方程式を見出した瞬間でものすごい分かったぞというね
ものすごい喜びを感じたんです
分かった これやと 存在っていう
これで全てやと これ以上は何もないし
これ以下も何もないんだ
うん 皆さんもその方程式知っておけばね
簡単です それまたすごい難しいと思うでしょ？宇宙の全部存在のカラクリを説明する方程式
あれ アインシュタインのあれ何て言いますか？何でしたっけ？ EイコールMC二乗ってやつですか？ EイコールMC？ 二乗
光の Cは光の速度 エネルギーとマースと
Cは？ Cは光の速度ですか
速度 これは物質の説明なんですね
それ足らんとその人は思ってはいたんですけど
一応未だにそれに置き換える方程式は誰も作ってないんです
だからCイコールMC二乗だから単純でしょ
そういう風にお釈迦様もある方程式をみんなにこれやと隠してないんです
全部言うんです 特許を取ろうとか思わなかったんです
みんなに全部秘密も何だかんでも堂々と言うんです
それでブッダの考え方と教えたものやらも至る所にあるんです
みんなにパクられたんです
聖書も何とか生き延びているのは仏教からもうパフォった言葉なんです
敵も愛しなさいとかね
欲張るなよと 持ってるものはみんなと分かりなさいと
そんなのはユダヤ教にある話じゃないんです
一つ すべて いつ何て言います？異物みたいな話なんです
神の教え自体すごい恐ろしいんですけど
その中にずっとこの共存する考え方が入っているんです
それは全部もうパーリ経典のお釈迦様がおっしゃったことと
一体そのものをいろいろあります
いろいろたとえで 物事を例えば神と業は全く言論はもう異端で
パガンの教えで何のことなく聖書にあるんです
人は仮にまく 自分でまくものは刈り取るんだと
そのまま言葉でお釈迦様おっしゃってます
人間の幸福というのは自分でまく種やと
ヤーリサンワプテーベージャンターリサンハルテーバラ
自分が種まいた通りに結果が得るんだと
だから心の問題なんです
それはまあたとえ たとえという章がありますから
聖書に そこでまあこの種は石の上にまいたらどうなるか
鳥に食べられるだけだとかね
もう棘とかいっぱいある荒っぽいところにまいたら
ちょっと芽が出るかもしれません
それで終わっちゃいます
しかし 堅実としたところで種まいたらちゃんと実を実るでしょうとね
そんなのも仏教には昔ありましたけどね
まあこれはあまり認めてくれないんだしからね
それはそれで  まあとにかくいろんなところにブッダの教えが入ってるんです
誰でも生き延びるためにブッダにすがるんです
日本でもまあ私がブッダと
私が神やという宗教家がいるんです
でもどこかで仏教に因縁作ってかないとすぐ死んでしまうんです
だからどんな新興宗教現れても
何か仏教に因縁つけちゃうんです
別にブッダの教えじゃないんで
言ってることはとんでもないことなんですけど
それでもちょっと因縁つけただけでも生き延びられる
それぐらいすごい心理なんです
ブッダの心理は それで世の中はブッダ自身の生の教えだけは聞きたくない
誰かにほんの一部パクられて
それで言うインチキばっかりすると
すぐ私も仏教を知ってるんだぞとかね
ということになるんです
まあだからまあブッダ自身の考え方を勉強するのはそんなことは悪くないと思いますね
それでこの方程式なんですけど
すべての存在の秘密を解読する
知らない？知ってるんでしょ？隠してないんだから
ずーっと言ってるんです
仏教で 何のこともない
これを因果論ということで言ったことないんですか？因縁論とか因果法則とか因果だよとかね
そう言うとものすごくなんか知識の面かぶろう
あ なんだそれかと だから子供にしかわからないんですよ
このすべての存在の秘密を解読する
で方程式はね これがあるからこれがあると
アスマインサティイダンホーティ
これがあるとこれがある
これが生まれるとこれが生まれる
これがない場合はこれもない
これが消えてしまうとこれも消えてしまうと
それだけです これ数学に入れちゃうと A
があるならばBもある A
がなくなるでBもなくなる A
があるからBがあると言っちゃうと足りません
証明するためにはAがない場合はやっぱりBもないんだよと
従ってAがある時はBがあると
で それ2番目のセットでAが生まれるとBも生まれると
で その正しいか調べるためにAが生まれてない場合はBも生まれていない
それが方程式の全く数学的におっしゃっているんです
それでそれがいろんなところに応用して
生命に 命に 人間の苦しみに
いろんなところに応用してみせるんです
だからそれは自分で発見すると全部知ったことになるんだ
その時に そういうことで
お釈迦様がこの悟ったことでも
この上ない喜びを感じて
で それでこの宇宙の秘密たる因果法則をね
で 神と言えばよくわからないでしょう
因果法則といえばすごい具体的でわかるでしょう
因果法則で説明できるものは何一つもないんです
だから仏教では奇跡は成り立たないんです
イティイマスミンサティイダンホーティ
これがある時はこれがある
イマスッタダイダンウッパティ
これが生まれる時 これも生まれるということで
生命の苦しみの因果法則を語って
それでお釈迦様はこの自分の喜びを表現するんです
これ大変有名な偈で もう仏教はすごい嫌い
破壊してやるぞと思っている学者の方々も
みんなまとめて これはものすごい古い言葉で
もうブッダ自身の言葉ですよとしか言いようがないと
なんとかその日本の学者もそう言うんです
エゲーガリマス ヤダハウェーパートバワンティダンマアターピノージャハイトーブラマナッサアタッサカンカーワパヤン
サッバ ヤトパジャナティ
サヘトゥダンマ ヤダハヴェー
パアトゥバワンティダンマ
ダンマってのは物事 全てのものなんですね
パアトゥバワンティ見えてくると現れになってくると
こういうことだ これはこれやと見えてくると
アタピノジャヘトゥブラフマナッサ
これすっごい修行しないとできるものじゃないんです
しっかりと物事を見る
見ないとわからないんです
固定概念持ってみるっていうことは
ブッダから見ればもう絶対真理に至らないんです
大人と子供の違うところはそちらにあるんです
大人が完全な無知で 子供はもう何も知らんからね
知らないだけのことで知り得る能力を失ってないんです
大人になるということは
何か知るわけじゃなくて
知り得る能力を失うんです
色々固定概念ばっかり叩くんです
大人になる過程で教育ということで
だから別に子供は全て知っているわけじゃないんです
知り得る能力知っています
だからデータそのまま受け取っちゃうんです
だから飼っていたネズミが死んじゃうと悲しいんです
だからこの知り得る能力を失って固定概念でっていうことは大変ですよ
だからまだありのままに見るということに戻らなくちゃいけないんです
見たくないという状態から
やっぱり見てみようかなというね
これができなくてみんな大変苦しんでるみたいです
瞑想したって全くもう成長は見えませんというか
ほとんど見えないんです
ただ自分のくだらないアホな固定概念を捨てちゃえばいいのに
それを捨てません 幽霊信じるバカがそのままもう瞑想するんです
神を信じているバカもまたそのまま瞑想にかかってくるんです
あれこれくだらないことを調べて修行して
ヨーガやって いろんなことやって
もうそれで納得いかなかったら
そのまんまで その知識に基づいてブッダの瞑想をやってみろと
全然 1ミリも進まないんです
固定概念で 知り得る能力を失っているんだから
もうちょっとそれで直せと
随分シンプルにできますよ
ま そういうことで この真理そのまま
あ こういうことか こういうことか
こういうことかと見えてくるのは固定概念ない人なんです
だからしっかりと集中して
しっかりと物事をありのままに見る人にはそのまま見えてくるんだと
見えてきたらどうなるんですか？アタッサカンカーヴァパヤンティサッバ
すべての欲が消えてしまうんだと
なるほど こういうことかと発見すると
どれぐらい楽しいと思いますかね
全存在の秘密 秘密も何も
なんだこれやと わかると何一つも義っていうのは残らないんです
一切義が消えたっていうことは
もう全部知ったっていうことなんです
で ヤトパジャナーティサヘトゥダンマ
全ての物事は因縁により生まれるものやと知ると
もう何の疑問もないんだよ
これがこのブッダが解く悟りの表現なんです
これはもう悟りましたよっていう意味なんです
もう問題はないと もうこれっきり
もう悩みも苦しみも悲しみも期待も
これからということは何にもなくなっちゃったと
いうことで この真理を知ることが幸福であると
それが苦しみをなくす道であるということになったんです
他の方法は何やっても何にもできないと
ということで  まあこのブッダの瞑想でこの疑をなく
疑がなく 疑っての他ということ
何だろうか それでいてこの上ない喜びが生まれてくる
私はこれからどうしようかという疑問が出てこなくなっちゃうんです
私は一体どうなるんでしょうかとかね
それもなくなる もう疑がないんです
だから人間考えられるいかなる問題であろうとも
疑ない理法には成り立ちません
そこが本当かというためには
人間があれこれやと疑問
問題があるならば出してみれば
因果法則を知っていると
本当か？全て解決できるのかと
あなたには だからオープンチャレンジです
ですから 皆様はブッダにも答えられない疑問があるならば出してみてください
これから考えて  一つお伺いします
はい  本当の自分とかですね
真実の自我とか  ん？ 真実の自我とかね
本当の自分とか いろいろありまして
本当の自分にね 戻ることが大切ですよと
本当の自分？ 本当の自分に戻ることが大切ですと
それはあなた方がさっき言った固定概念ですね
いろんな固定概念で体中を囲まれちゃって
汚れを着てますよと この汚れを 1つずつ取り去って
自分の自分をその囲んでいる余分なものを取り除いちゃってですね
本来の本当の自分に戻りなさいというようなことを言う人はいるんですけれども
その本当の自分というのはどんなものだと考えていらっしゃいますか？ はい
その問題にも大きな問題があるでしょ
本当の自分に戻りなさいと言うために
何の証拠あるんですかね
固定概念ですよ 知らないくせに
もう今の見せかけの自分で苦しんでるんだから
もう本当の自分に戻ればいいんじゃないか
だから本当の自分に戻れとお前知ってるのかと
という疑問が だからそれも結局は固定概念なんです
ではなくて 自分って何なのかと
まず具体的に小学生ぐらいのものに戻って
それ調べるんです 自分って何なのかと
自分という実感があるんです
確かに人間に 実感があるんだったら
それが何かと具体的なことでしょうね
それ調べるものであって
科学的に言えばそれ全部調べようとしないで
やっぱり本当の自分に戻らなくちゃいけないんだという
どういうことですかね
神がいるとの証拠を出さないで
神を信じなさいということと同じでしょうに
だからその問題の場合でも同じことなんです
やっぱり固定概念に凝り固まってます
ヴィパッサナー瞑想っていうのは
自分とは何やということは具体的にチェックすることです
それが別に本当の自分なんですよ
もし本当の自分があったら
別にそれ本当の自分です
もう戻るも話にならんでしょうに
だからその考え方自体の矛盾なんで
どうやって自分が別な自分でいられますか
ずっと自分は自分でしょう
いつでも我々は本当の自分でいるんですよ
怒るときは本気で怒るんです
演技してるわけじゃないんです
演じてる場合でも自分で知ってるんです
これは演技やと だから本当の自分というのは瞬間たりとも失ったことがないんですよ
現実の自分は本当の自分
現実の自分が現実の自分は本当の自分なんです
それに戻る戻る では 現実の自分に戻って何かいいことはあるのかと
それが苦というんですよ
怒るときは本気で怒りますよ
欲張るときも同じでしょう
これがいいやと 偽りないでしょうに
ただお世辞でああ 美しいですねと言うときの心を知ってるんだから
これお世辞ばっかりの自分がお世辞言ってるんだと
その方が楽やと だからいつでも生命っていうのは本当の自分でいるんです
それがちょっと忘れちゃうと精神的に病気というんです
そういう時は病院に行くしかないんです
でも病院に行くほど派手にそのまで問題を起こす人々っていうのは少ないでしょうに
それで私はこの精神的な病気の人々とも話したりすることありますけど
あり得もしない妄想でもうむちゃくちゃ苦しんでますよ
これが我々も悟る前限りは同じことやっています
今の質問にあったような感じでも
本当の自分に戻れという考え方も同じことなんです
もうとっくに本当の自分なのに
本当はその人とわからないまま本当の自分なんです
これはもうロクなことじゃないんですよ
本当の自分は だから別なところにあるんじゃないかなという
何考えてるんでしょうね
我々はインチキで怒るわけでも
インチキで欲張るわけでもないんです
欲しいと思った時は正直に欲しいんです
怒るときも正直に怒ってるんです
それってロクなものじゃないんだからね
だったらこれはロクなものじゃないと理解すれば
それだけの話でしょうに
欲張ったり怒ったりするんだけど
結局ロクな結果もないし
自己管理もできんし なんで惨めやと
生きることはと ところでストップするんです
だから命は惨めなりと
で ストップすればいいところで
では本当にそうでない
本当の自分はどこにあるのかっていうところで終わり
人間の知恵の世界の思考は
何にもできなくなっちゃうんです
またぐるぐるぐるぐる妄想ね
回ることになるんです
すごい微妙なんです だから世の中で言ってることは
いっつも仏教にはもう合わない
まるっきり仏教はもうすごい違うんです
言ってるんで だから他の修行で言ってることを持ってきて
それも立派な考え方やと
その上で仏教を組み立てましょう
そこで概念潰さないと
ということです これって我々のあるすごい大きな精神的な病気なんですね
完璧な自分がどこかに別なところにあるんじゃないかなと
そんなこと まあ人を殺す人も同じこと言うんです
本当は殺すつもりではなかったと
何言うんでしょうか 殺すつもりではなかったなら殺さんでしょうに
殺してからこれがまずいとわかるとあんなこと言うんです
自分が本当はそんな悪い人間じゃないんだぞと
何なんですか 殺すつもりないんだったら殺さないよ
殴るつもりなかったら殴りませんよ
自分の子供はもう自分と遊んで
もうもう膝の上に座って
また体に乗ったりして
また背中にまで乗ったりして
もうもう足を首に巻けて
もうもう頭を捕まっていろいろ遊んでいると
もう可愛いでしょうね
じゃあ殺してやるぞと
誰もするんです その時は
その時は逆に子供だからもうふざけて遊んでいて
ちょっと転がしちゃって頭でも打ったら大変やってことでしっかり体しっかりしてるだけでしょうに
子供は不注意で滑ったりしちゃうとすぐ捕まってあげなくちゃいけないんだとかね
その時は可愛い可愛い可愛いって気分でいるでしょう
それでも親が子供を殺すケースっていうのはいくらでもあるでしょ
泣き止まなかったんだからとか
夜泣いたんだからって赤ちゃん殺すでしょ
後から殺すつもりではなかったとかなんのんですかね
みんな正直ですよ 本当は
汚いところは否定するところなんです
そこが頭の病気 精神的な病気なんです
瞑想はそれを直すしてるんです
それを直しちゃうと たとえ子供が夜泣きしたんだからといって
もう腹が立って殺そうということになりません
本当の自分を認めると
これろくな自分じゃないんですよ
本当の自分という 無知の塊で
感情的で 反射的で 決まってるパターンでロボットみたいに生きてるんです
そうすると本当の自分に対してすごく諦めることです
執着しないことになるんです
そんなの捨てちまいって気分になるんです
自分というもの その人は救われます
もうロボットじゃないんです
綺麗なもの見た時に あ
欲しいって そうサボったじゃないんです
嫌なことやったらものすごいもうもうもうカッとなると思うわけね
サボったじゃないんです
それが心のことなんです
だからその智慧を開発しなさいと
はい 今日は長い時間その辺りもしゃべりましたけど
では 何か他のお質問ございますか
[背景音楽]